fait tous et sans respect tout dans
votre sang me dis pas rassurez vous dans
leur réalité tout ça mais voilà pour les
gens qui nous regardent question tous
les réponses twitter pardon voilà et
voilà une fois de plus daniele moyer
annonce est maintenant mais il se
félicite que mâcon où à chaque fois
commun et maintenant les amis on n'a pas
pu avoir stéphane bern donc on a eu lieu
au mont ont fait le point princesse
jingle il est beaucoup moins cher les
amis vous l'avez lu où vous l'avez
entendu dans la presse people pref et on
amador la réponse parce que du coup
personne ne sait si c'est vrai ou pas
kate et mégane donc les deux femmes deux
ce serait la guerre ça chauffe à
buckingham palace selon la presse
anglaise donc plus rien ne va entre kate
middleton et meghan markle pire
l'ambiance serait tellement tendue que
megan harry aurait décidé de déménager
donc face au succès grandissant de
mégane qui copine avec la reine alors
que cahill pas du tout et ben
aujourd'hui elle serait énervée elle ne
pourrait plus se supporter tout est
résumé ici et derrière on aura enfin les
vraies réponses
est ce que c'est la presse people qui a
monté tout ça ou est ce que c'est la
réalité regardez il y a quinze jours on
voulait montrer côte-à-côte chats sont
aujourd'hui très loin
regardez sur la photo officielle des 70
ans du prince charles publiées cette
semaine kate et megan sont à l'opposé
l'une de l'autre
l'une en mode mamie l'autre en mode mort
de rire
difficile de faire plus éloignés ça sent
le rififi entre les princesses à en
croire la presse ce qui exaspère kate
middleton se le côté star californienne
de meghan markle cool et décontracté à
l'américaine mais n'hésitant pas à jouer
les intrigantes ouvriers 2011 megan la
chouchoute de la famille royale et vas-y
que je rigole avec la reine tandis que
kate se prend avant lors des
commémorations du 11 novembre
et vas-y que je n'assure que les
événements de l'amour alors qu'au même
moment la gentille qu'elle se tape le
service de la soupe pour une association
une kate middleton tellement jalouse que
pour éclipser sa nouvelle rivale elle
serait de nouveau enceinte
mais un quatrième enfant c'est pas sûr
que ce soit le bon choix pour gagner la
bataille du glamour acquise hington
balah centre e will i am a ri et leurs
épouses
il y aurait comme tu déménagement dans
l'aide mais que kate se rassure selon un
sondage elle qui nous a fait tant rêver
de 7 64% d'opinions favorables auprès
des anglais alors que megan stagne à 55%
alors la guerre entre kate et mégane
chic rock où j'y crois pas
voilà la question est posée la guerre
entre kate et mégane pardon j'y crois
j'y crois pas a répondu évidemment sur
sur twitter avec le hashtag tpm people
pour ne dire si selon vous c'est vrai ou
c'est la presse people qui veut gagner
un peu d'argent autour de la table on a
beaucoup beaucoup de j'y crois pas en a
que deux qui croit on va commencer pas
elle va commencer par un j crois lui
quand je vais moi ce qui me pardonneront
joie jusqu'à plus de vous dire les deux
qui sont à la tête de magazines people
est en général plutôt bien informés au
lendemain pour le mans depuis quelques
semaines qu'on fait l'émission ensemble
c'est rare qui est une bêtise en une
les deux y croit les autres de 2,2
closer pourquoi est ce que vous croyez
vraiment à cette guerre vous parce qu'il
ya des bascules et des arguments parce
que la presse anglaise qui pour le coup
fait déclasser des quotidiens dont
qu'ils ont de quoi écrire et puis ils
ont vraiment des chroniqueurs au palais
tout le temps le raconte d'une manière
très précise que toutes les façons
mégane a attiré toute la lumière sur
elle et c'est vrai que kate middleton a
de quoi en prendre ombrage que meghan
markle des vrais cette star
hollywoodienne une actrice elle est mal
élevé finalement par rapport à kate qui
fait tout bien
et il ya un côté ou forcément ça est la
quête mégane et à rio il ya trois
personnes en six mois qui ont qui ont
quitté leurs services ah oui ça c'est
quand même des faits canton parce
qu'elle est trop capricieuse parce
qu'elle est euros elle est trop comme
vous en fait est là elle est trop diva
et du coup il ya peu c'était ni de
travailler pour vous voyez toujours il
me donnait qu'il est je suis artistique
l'autre jour les gens finir par vous
croire du tout et du coup j'étais
directeur qui sait tout pour faire
bizarre ou halak et qui sert la soupe
aux vieux effet terraké super elle et
elle est reine prend toute la lumière
elle trouve ça injuste et c'est vraiment
qu'un gant vous la soupe bio tout ça
c'est vraiment cette mission
est-ce que non mais j'ignorais cette
information générale excuse ce sont des
informations que vous avez parce que
vous avez des contacts en angleterre en
tant que magazine people entre magazine
people
ou est ce que vous lisez la presse
people anglaise et du compte la main
mais c'est les deux c'est quoi des
correspondants qui vont nous donner des
mesures correspondant souvent lisent la
presse alors vous savez d'affaires qu'à
l'allier une personne qui verrait ses
trios merci asador nous parler un petit
peu les uns sur les autres 1 s'est dit
sûr sur twitter c'est vrai qu'on la
surnomme l'ouragan mégane paraît voilà
le s'élève à 5 heures du matin elle a
jusqu'à sept messages par jour aux
assistants bas il paraît qu'elle a bien
pris son rôle de
deux premières dames à coeur alors j'y
crois pas catherine alors moi je les
adore tous les deux l'udc et myriam et c
est leur intérêt de d'y croire pour
faire marcher leurs deux intéressés pas
de mentir c'est que bhagan août et ça ça
les arrange bien quand même
mais voilà c'est passé coûte vraiment
cette histoire est moi je sais pas que
je connais pas très bien les relations
entre les deux mais c'est venus
notamment du de l'aménagement qui était
annoncé du prince à rédené gave au
palais de kensington hockey à tampa et
de kensington ya déjà william et kate
il y a aussi le duc de kent le prince de
kent et le duc de gloucester donc et
finalement ils ne vont pas s'installer
au palais kate et mégane pourquoi parce
que le palais est plein à craquer et
dont les amis ghana qui trépigne depuis
ledit mouvement se dit ravie risée des
bouquins sur les faits à 6 ans alors
maintenant mais pour le coup il est
vraiment très renseigné là dessus on la
remercie pour moi
les amis à tous en même temps s'il vous
plaît pas ce qu'il vient de dire que lui
va vous êtes plus dur j'y crois leur
amour n'est aujourd'hui black friday ou
c'est le black friday c'est le lendemain
de thanksgiving est une tradition
américaine où on mange une dinde et
compagnie ce café meghan markle hier
soir à l'invité donc sa belle soeur et
son beau-frère et des médias elle a fait
justement une tradition américaine bon
bref
aujourd'hui il est de bon ton de les
opposer mais on a fait avec mathieu on
produit des émissions de télévision un
documentaire il ya quelques temps sur
sur justement catég l'âme et on le
disait et les spécialistes britanniques
et tous ceux qui sont les meilleurs là
tu disais vous allez voir on va chercher
à les imposer
on va chercher à les mettre en guerre
parce que ça arrange parce que ça
arrange tout le monde
la seule gagnante de tout ça c'est la
couronne c'est la reine d'angleterre le
monde est cristallisée sur ces deux
personnes là le monde ça fait gagner
beaucoup d'argent
la reine se ce guillaume en dit la même
chose arrive la reine surkiffe tout ça
en fait la reine s'est d'abord occupé de
kate middleton
au début pour la forme et maintenant
donc on a dit que c'était la chouchoute
évidemment il y en avait pas d'autres
aujourd'hui queen elizabeth elle
s'occupe de la petite mégane et quelle
forme alors oui on a tendance un peu à
croire que megan se prend pour une star
américaine en attendant elle ne quitte
pas ils ont toujours 22 pièces à
kensington
il se trouve juste que megan elle n'a
pas été élevé dans l'aristocratie elle a
envie d'un beau d'avoir pour son enfant
un enfant de l'élever de manière normale
elle sait exactement comme kate et
william ont fait kate et william quand
ils ont eu deux pépites peu de premiers
patineurs qui sont allés à la campagne
se remet d'un accord passé bien ils vont
faire ils font exactement pareil ils
prennent une maison à la campagne pour
élever leurs enfants de manière normale
c'est l'héritage de diana élever vos
enfants de manière normale j'ai bien
aucune guerre entre tout le monde
s'arrache en arrange kate et william
ce qui est bien c'est là c'est l'enfant
chéri la session spéciale guy tout ira
bien en gros tout va bien et ça c'est un
fonds alors moi je pose une question
myriem quand même parce que je reste
quand même persuadé que pour le moment -
téléspectateurs je n'ai pas ces infos
toutes les lumières et sur mégane elle
est plus jolie nouvelle et sympathique
elle est surveillante ciel nouvelle lady
di la reine mère l'adorent alors qu'elle
parle pas à l'autre moi je reste
persuadé que quand tu as deux filles
comme ça qu'ils sont en concurrence est
tout ne peut pas si bien allez olla là
mais ça c'est forcément deux filles ça
se détestent vous avez dit ça qui vient
de rennes
non comparer les haut-parleurs myriam
jacques pouget a beaucoup mieux mais on
n'a pas les mêmes informateurs
lorsque depuis qu'elle est enceinte
c'est vraiment la cata elle est
extrêmement insupportable au palais
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
elle va pas y rester longtemps qui
enceinte bague mais aussi pardon pas
aussi de quelques quêtes annexes
donc depuis qu'elle est depuis qu'elle
est enceinte elle est insupportable et
pour la première fois quand même les
deux frères ont toujours été très
proches depuis la mort de leur mère vont
avoir un staff différent celui d'une
communication différente et selon mes
informations c'est uniquement parce que
le tout le staff de harry a peur que l'
influence de megan non le stade de
williams a peur que l' influence de
mégane sur harry soit mauvaise donc
alors chéri alors alors chéri les jeunes
ça court vite mais les vieux ça connaît
le chemin
j'étais mieux
donna port de tartous a déjà tout ça a
déjà eu lieu c'est juste que leurs
cabinets se séparent pourquoi parce
qu'ils ont deux familles différentes qui
sont en train de créer 2 comment dire
deux de bonnes oeuvres qui fait que
l'équipe ne peut pas se contenter de
faire le film
il ya un vrai vrai on n'a pas la réponse
on aura dans quelques semaines
certainement c'est se crêpent le chignon
si elles sont copines
en attendant qu'est ce que pensent les
gens ce que cette fois ci encore vous
avez raison mon ghetto j'y crois j'y
crois pas d'accord voilà